another day another shocking report
about zero experience hunter biden and
of course the biden family syndicate new
york times reporting that our hunter
biden linked investment firm helped the
chinese company purchase a cobalt mine
from an american business now that's the
metal that is essential for the
manufacturing of batteries and electric
vehicles uh talk about american last
policies that's about it now at time
source says hunter didn't directly
profit from the deal uh are we really to
believe he worked for free i don't
believe that because he's charging an
awful lot of money for his paint by
numbers uh portraits of a crack addict
here with reaction outkick founder
co-host of the clay travis buck sexton
uh show as well as fox news contributor
jason chavez uh i don't believe he did
it for free he and the bigger issue that
we needed answer to is joe biden is
allowing
vladimir putin to build up an army on
the border with ukraine it looks like
military action is imminent and joe
biden is allowing china to fly their
fighter jets over taiwan airspace every
day and talk about reunification my
argument is that the biden's a
compromise because they because hunter
got money from both countries
jason
that's abs absolutely right sean uh i i
guess i'll go ahead and take that one um
it's absolutely right look the smartest
person on the planet according to joe
biden is hunter biden it happens to be
his son his son has had deals in ukraine
his son has has deals in china he has
taken millions of dollars uh from the
former mayor of moscow's wife and he
tried to do deals with some very
influential people in mexico you know
what's missing from that list doing
deals the better the united states of
america he hasn't done that and now he's
got this
ridiculous deal with himself in the
white house to say hey i'm going to go
out and sell this art for 450 000 of pop
even though the united states senate the
year before said that's how the russians
launder money so given all of that there
needs to be a special prosecutor
republicans better get their act
together sean because every single
republican in the house in the senate
should be signing on to a letter
demanding from the attorney general that
we have to have a special prosecutor
it's what democrats did to trump and
what republicans are just whimpish on
they're going to go into the second half
of the ball game 2022 and they're going
to say we're winning and they're not
going to want to do anything bold
because they think they're winning and
they're gonna let this guy get get away
for free
clay let's get your take
oh sean look everything that hunter
biden is doing is what they all said at
the new york times and cnn and msnbc in
the washington post that was happening
with the trump kids can you imagine if
any of these stories imagine if don jr
had decided to get into painting and
start to sell paintings for 500 000 to
russian oligarchs can you imagine if uh
if anybody in the trump family had
decided you know what let's make sure
that we're working to get a
multi-billion dollar deal through for
chairman z and everybody in china can
you imagine the relationships there
everything that the mainstream media
told you was happening with the trump
kids is actually occurring with hunter
biden and it's as if nobody wants to
acknowledge all of it no by the way we
know joe biden himself was involved in
all these deals it's shameful it's
pathetic and once more everything they
accuse trump of doing joe biden and his
family they've actually done it sean
yeah let's see we got uh three and a
half million from a russian oligarch we
got the 1.5 billion dollar deal with the
bank china we got a hundred thousand
dollar shopping spree with the chinese
national joe biden doesn't take on china
doesn't take on russia i would say that
needs an investigation it's amazing all
right clay thank you jason thank you
when we come back an announcement about
tomorrow night's show straight ahead